frédéric sinclair politologue et auteur
bonjour frédéric saint clair merci
d'être avec nous cet après midi sur rt
france
alors cette possibilité d'une alliance
des partis de gauche on en a souvent
entendu parler par le passé on sait que
ça souvent été compliqué est ce que
cette fois c'est possible j'ai bien peur
que ça soit aussi impossible que les
fois précédentes pour une raison bien
simple c'est que les signataires même de
cette pétition ne sont pas d'accord
entre c'est à dire que quand on liés à
la pétition on se rend compte que les
mots qui sont utilisés sont des mots
valises qui sont très présents dans
l'idéologie de la gauche donc on a
toutes les oppositions au
présidentialisme au racisme à
l'exclusion au capitalisme au
productivisme et donc là j'allais dire
quelque part presque toute la gauche
pourraient se rassembler derrière ces
termes et ensuite on a une adhésion à
l'écologie à la démocratie à la question
sociale est là encore une fois à peu
près toute la gauche pourrait se ranger
derrière ces mots là sauf que quand on
rentre dans le détail il n'y a pas de
détails dans ce texte
mais quand on rentre dans le détail on
se rend compte que c'est là que se
révèle la totalité des fractures de la
gauche que l'on connaît et qui ne sont
pas simplement lié à des querelles de
partis d'ego de tactique qui sont liées
vraiment à des différences idéologiques
très forte
vous parlez de ses fractures est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus sur
justement s'est fracturé un qui qui
séparent tous et tous ces partis de
gauche
oui alors la première et elle est liée à
ce terme là qui est le capitalisme donc
ce modèle libéral de fabrication de la
richesse qui qu'on connaît depuis la
révolution industrielle au 19e siècle
qui a donné naissance à toutes les
oppositions socialiste à travers le
19ème et le 20ème siècle
ce capitalisme là petit à petit la
gauche pendant deux siècles s'y rallier
de plus en plus massivement et
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron est un pur
produit de ce ralliement faut pas
oublier que son mentor celui qui l'a
fait rentrer à la banque
rothschild et celui qu'il a ensuite
présenté à françois hollande pour qu'il
devienne son conseiller jacques attali
était membre du parti socialiste dès le
début des années 70 73 je crois et
ensuite a été le conseiller spécial de
françois mitterrand donc c'est bien de
cette gauche la socialiste qui avait
fait l'union son temps dont on pas quand
on parle de l'héritage intellectuel d'
emmanuel macron donc emmanuel macron ne
n'est pas de nulle part
il incarne une forme de gauche rallié à
la question libéral geste en a une autre
gauche c'est celle qui a affronté
pendant le mandat le quinquennat de
françois hollande
cette gauche qui est beaucoup plus
attachés à la question sociale beaucoup
plus ouverte sur les questions
sociétales et qui n'étaient pas d'accord
avec la politique de manuel valls et
ensuite on est encore une autre gauche
une gauche qui est aujourd'hui derrière
jean-luc mélenchon et qui est une gauche
qu'on appelle indigéniste des
colonialistes très ouverte à
l'immigration mais par contre
bizarrement très contraignantes au
niveau européen jean luc mélenchon a
assez différencier du soc habituel
universaliste de la gauche très ouvert
très mondialistes par 1 1
une opposition farouche à bruxelles qui
d'un certain côté pourrait le rapprocher
d'une extrême droite lepéniste
et puis ensuite vous avez encore une
autre gauche qui a fait de l'écologie
sont son centre de réflexion et qui
déduit toutes les autres questions de
l'écologie puis ensuite vous êtes encore
une autre gauche qui est une gauche
sociétale féministes qui n'a pas de
projet vraiment politique qui est une
gauche immigrationniste est une gauche
indigéniste et qui en réalité tant lutte
contre la république
on l'a vu très très fort pendant la
question adama traoré pendant les
leurres sauvagement donc cette c'est une
gauche qui ne voient les questions
régaliennes liés à la sécurité à la
justice qu'au travers du prisme de la
victimation cette gauche là n'est pas
représenté in extenso politiquement mais
par contre elle est très présente dans
la société elle est présente dans les
signataires qui alla donc vous voyez qui
en fait c'est le gaucher les
complètement morcelé au milieu il ya une
gauche républicaine qui essaye d'exister
et puis un dernier point vous avez une
gauche souverainiste qui commence à
monter très fort c'est la gauche de
michel onfray c'est le gauche là
aujourd'hui elle est très critiqué mais
michel onfray a lancé une
revue qui marche très bien qu'il ya
beaucoup d'échos et donc ça donne encore
une autre voie à une gauche qui
possiblement fait des alliances avec une
droite souverainiste et vous vous rendez
compte que cette gauche commune à
laquelle ses signataires appellent c'est
un leurre vous avez parlé de jean luc
mélenchon vous avez parlé de michel
onfray à l'instant beaucoup de noms vous
avez évoqué sur sur ces partis de gauche
si jamais dans l'hypothèse la gauche
venait à se rassembler est-ce qu'on
pourrait éventuellement dégager une
figure de une figure politique ou ou
philosophiques ou ou quelque chose
d'autre pour tenter de deux lits 17,7
gauche
alors pour pour chercher ensuite à
l'incarner politiquement et donc faire
surgir une figure il faut il faut
simplifier un tout petit peu ce que j'ai
dit et se recentre et finalement sur les
partis politiques parce que c'est quand
même eux qui guident l'opinion et qui
attire les suffrages au moment de
l'élection qui a t'on à gauche face à
nous aujourd'hui qui possiblement
pourrait rallier des suffrages on a
sonné que vous voyez à l'écran
yannick jadot donc ce personnage
aujourd'hui n'est pas ce n'est pas
symbolique à gauche vous avez vu que sur
dans l'est dans les sondages il ne
parvient pas à attirer à lui la
sympathie simplement de l'ensemble des
écologistes donc c'est une figure qui
commence à imprimer son image dans
l'opinion mais qui n'est pas
suffisamment charismatique pour attirer
tout le monde vous avez jean luc
mélenchon qui est en perte de vitesse et
qui incarne une gauche très particulière
il ya ce jeu nous poser à terre avenue
peu place de la république à paris à
l'époque du du du comité traoré et de la
fère floyd ce jean luc mélenchon qui
aujourd'hui est qualifié par certains à
gauche d'anti républicanisme tente il ay
la tendance à ouvrir la porte aux dés
colonialisme et à l'indigénisme et puis
ensuite vous avez un ps qui est depuis
la défaite de françois hollande
complètement mortifié presque inexistant
mais qui malgré tout est une structure
qui a une histoire et qui gardent des
références républicaine
sauf que la tête de ce ps olivier fort
que vous le voyez encore l'écran n'est
pas capable aujourd'hui de
fédérer la gauche et donc on a
absolument aucune personnalité politique
j'allais dire de terrain qui soit
capable de prendre le le commandement
d'une gauche unifiée et de dire derrière
moi font venir s'agréger la totalité des
voix et jean luc mélenchon dans une
interview assez récente a d'ailleurs
acter cette incapacité d'union de gauche
même s'il reconnaissait qu'il aimerait
bien se voir lui même c'est la
problématique des ego à gauche comme à
droite d'ailleurs si qu'il aimerait bien
se voir lui même comme leader d'une
opinion à gauche en réalité ce leader
n'existe pas et l'union des idées de
gauche c'est-à-dire un corpus commun
n'existe pas non plus merci beaucoup
frédéric saint clair d'avoir été avec
nous cet après midi sur rt france je
rappelle que vous êtes politologue et
auteur merci beaucoup